SF has a drug problem SF has a
cleanliness problem SF has an education
problem SF has an anti-tech problem SF
has a fundamentally political problem so
the question is how do we solve it I
still live in San Francisco my name is
Gary tan and I'm the head of why
combinator why combinator is the first
and probably the number one startup
incubator in the world by many measures
not being in San Francisco seems to lead
to failure and death and one of the
things we care a lot about for Founders
is we want them to be as successful as
possible and there are just so many
agglomeration effects for Founders
especially firsttime Founders well we
basically make every YC company come for
12 weeks so we give about half a million
dollars to teams of one two or three
people often with just an idea and we're
really interested in funding the
earliest possible people and a lot of
those people go on to create incredible
unicorn companies yeah I think one of
the best things that 20 somethings can
do is actually move to the places of the
highest concentration of the smart
people we're talking about parallel
education which is relevant to your
point about algebra and public middle
schools the reason why they removed
algebra from middle schools is this
really misguided idea that if you
detrack if you put students of all the
different levels into the same class the
smart kids are going to pull up uh the
kids who are behind and practice that
just isn't true we can't allow the
political machine to just you get the
worst possible outcomes like let's
create more growth engines let's create
more progress let's create more
technological process we have to
accelerate through this and at the same
time we need to worry about media we
need to worry about politics we need to
worry about Academia and we need to pull
those people along and so you're
absolutely right bology we need our own
parallel media we need our own machine
and it has to be built in the image of
this growth mindset because and we need
a lot more technology to do it so what's
next for San Francisco we've stated the
problem we've outlined the political
machine and we've talked about how we've
replaced some pieces of that political
machine specifically we have a parallel
media now with elon's Twitter or X
getting a parallel media was a key piece
uh and it wasn't done through voting it
was by building voting is important as
it sets the laws and policies of our
society but on its own it just replaces
the elected officials we need to replace
the unelected parts of the system as
well building parallel education
nonprofits media unions and that's what
the network state conference is about
each replacement doesn't have to be a on
toone but it probably should be internet
first and stand alone in terms of its
business business model but also
interlocking with the others that's a
possible recipe for reforming San
Francisco and building the alternative
Tech political machine and if it works
in SF it will work everywhere and the
cool thing about it is this is just
getting started oh this is great thank
you man